a great cast you were and I know that
you guys are close you can tell when you
watch the movie that you guys to have a
bond great group of people I love all of
them JJ set such a great tone and I
think cast the movie so well with people
who would complement each other not just
in their work but in how we live our
lives and so yeah Chris Pine and I are
really tight and John Cho and Simon and
Benedict is a new addition Benedict
Cumberbatch the greatest name I've ever
heard
Benedict Cumberbatch and he's a he's a
man to match his name he's a great guy
and so yeah we all we all enjoyed our
camaraderie both making the movie and
then promoting it which was great you
know it's good to hang out with those
guys and and stir up trouble wherever we
go I understand there's actually some
evidence you guys know it's a concern
Francisco yeah well I think there's a
first of all it began the evening begins
innocently enough Simon it's it's a
picture I think I stand innocent enough
at Hooters where most innocent evenings
begin yeah sure
we were there was a big fight on and we
were just wrapping the movie in Northern
California so we all met at a Hooters
and then from the Hooters we went into
the night of San Francisco and things
went downhill from there or up grandma
peg grandma peg as we call Paul Simon
grandma yeah cuz he was the designated
track for that night and for some reason
his rental car was this like you know
Buick LeSabre or some kind of like
grandma car he was just in the front
seat like not really able to drive very
well but taking us all it was great you
did I think you have a picture of the
beginning of the evening everything
why are you sure looks like this on
something
don't think Simon was okay there's a
reason he was driving that slowly and
then you also Simon later tweeted
footage from later on in the night I
don't know I haven't seen this yet
that's actually great that's fun I think
it's good that I'm the one doing the
cabbage bag is that what it's always a
good cabbage patch well sure in the
butter that's something else
cabbage patch you know that's like the
witch's brew oh I do it yeah I keep it
tight and I'm the churning butter
yeah it's Salem Massachusetts and I'm
spec of 16 I'm making butter you've
become very very close with Leonard
Nimoy it's true one of the Great's of
all time and you guys actually have
formed kind of a kind of a fun bond you
did a project together
well we very recently do yes we did a
little short film for Audi which hit the
internet this week and and really got it
was a it was a real tidal wave of a
video what do they call that on the
internet when something gets real crazy
viral there you go
yeah it was a real it was a real viral
experience on the internet this week
I've never had any I got like four
million views and one-nighters we have
we have it actually and I believe the
setup is it's you and Leonard are very
competitive yeah when you're racing to a
country club to have lunch and whoever
gets there last has to pay right so you
guys are giving each other a hard time
let's look at this Audi spot I'm already
here
they are already feel like I'm stuck in
a black hole no worries I can practice
my swing if you need to pull over and
take a nap smart
I have been and always shall be your
friend
really I had nice try you know no I
definitely had not for a second
obviously your Bangla technically we're
not inside yet
[Applause]